This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Crave, Netflix, and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Crave, Netflix, and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。真人保证。获取 Bell 纯光纤网络，搭配 Crave、Netflix 和 Disney Plus，每月 94 加元起。两年期网络且开通自动付款优惠的两年价格保证。访问 bell.ca 了解详情并查看可用性。Bell，连接就是一切。嘿，波特兰迪亚的粉丝们。我是凯莉·布朗斯坦和弗雷德·阿米森。
The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, A.O. rewatch, our brand-new podcast, where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chryssel,
The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, A.O. rewatch, our brand-new podcast, where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chryssel,|||90 年代的梦想在播客形式中重现。我们正在推出《波特兰迪亚》A.O.重看版，这是我们的全新播客，我们将一起重温《波特兰迪亚》的每一集，剖析小品，深入探讨我们的标志性角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。我们还将邀请那些帮助将其变为现实的人们加入我们。客串明星、合作者和朋友，包括导演乔纳森·克里塞尔，
the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia AEO rewatch on the IHeart
the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia AEO rewatch on the IHeart|||市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦、传奇音乐家艾米·曼恩等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥了，不仅是台词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为你们都会写一首歌。我记得你当时是这么想的。收听 IHeart 上的 Podlandia AEO 重看版播客
Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My first guest is Karas Hilton, Shakira, Luke, and Yerrin. Have surprises? Many surprises. Welcome to the Sweet 305 podcast
Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My first guest is Karas Hilton, Shakira, Luke, and Yerrin. Have surprises? Many surprises. Welcome to the Sweet 305 podcast|||广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何您获取播客的地方。我的第一位嘉宾是卡拉斯·希尔顿、夏奇拉、卢克和耶林。有惊喜吗？很多惊喜。欢迎来到甜蜜 305 播客
where the group check comes to life. What on? You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. This is Sweet 305. Here, oversharing is encouraged. Listen to Sweet
where the group check comes to life. What on? You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. This is Sweet 305. Here, oversharing is encouraged. Listen to Sweet|||团队盘点在这里成为现实。为了什么？你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。那是柠檬味的。这里是甜蜜 305。在这里，过度分享受到鼓励。收听甜蜜
3.05 with Lillipons on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and IHart Women's Sports. We're breaking down the biggest headlines. Naomi Osaka, showing out. Shoutouts to you, Naomi. The viral moments. I've been obsessed with Kashan Rock's boxing journey. She looks good. Her combos are swift. And the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Jake Brennan,
3.05 with Lillipons on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and IHart Women's Sports. We're breaking down the biggest headlines. Naomi Osaka, showing out. Shoutouts to you, Naomi. The viral moments. I've been obsessed with Kashan Rock's boxing journey. She looks good. Her combos are swift. And the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Jake Brennan,|||3.05，与莉莉庞斯一起，在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 或任何您获取播客的地方。大家好，家人们？我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯。嘿，大家好？我是你们的女孩萨姆·J。我们是《每个人都看女子体育》的主持人，这是 Together 和 IHart 女子体育的全新播客。我们正在剖析最大的头条新闻。大坂直美，表现出色。向你致敬，娜奥米。病毒式传播的时刻。我一直沉迷于卡山·罗克的拳击之旅。她看起来状态很好。她的组合拳很敏捷。以及大家在女子体育界谈论的故事。因为每个人都看女子体育。在 Iheart 电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何您获取播客的地方收听《每个人都看女子体育》。我是杰克·布伦南，
and on the Disgraceland podcast, I explore the wild lives of rock stars and unbelievable true crime stories from music history. These are the stories you haven't heard, the kind you'll end up telling someone else. Like the time Paul McCartney spent in a notorious prison or the bizarre crime Lady Gaga is accused her, or that time Blondie's Debbie Harry escaped Ted Bundy. Listen to Disgraceland on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. This episode is a rerun. Hello everybody.
and on the Disgraceland podcast, I explore the wild lives of rock stars and unbelievable true crime stories from music history. These are the stories you haven't heard, the kind you'll end up telling someone else. Like the time Paul McCartney spent in a notorious prison or the bizarre crime Lady Gaga is accused her, or that time Blondie's Debbie Harry escaped Ted Bundy. Listen to Disgraceland on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. This episode is a rerun. Hello everybody.|||在《黑历史乐园》播客中，我探索了摇滚巨星的狂野生活以及音乐史上难以置信的真实犯罪故事。这些都是你没听过的事，那种你会忍不住讲给别人听的故事。比如保罗·麦卡特尼在臭名昭著的监狱里度过的时间，或者Lady Gaga被指控的离奇罪行，或者金发美女黛比·哈里逃离泰德·邦迪的经历。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何您获取播客的地方收听《黑历史乐园》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们讨论二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。本期节目是重播。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Have you ever been told that you're too sensitive or that you just shouldn't think so much? You're overreacting to something so small. You let the world hurt you or my all-time favorite. You just take everything so personally. If you are, you're overreacting to something so small, you're overreacting to something so small. You let the world hurt you or my all-time favorite. You just take everything so personally. If you are, if you are, are a highly sensitive person, these statements are definitely something that you've probably encountered and are most likely sick of hearing. Being a highly sensitive person is so much more than what people think it is. There is such a limited idea that if you're sensitive, you must cry all the time, you ever react, you take things too seriously, that you make it difficult for others. Sensitivity is often synonymous with fragility, being easy to break and feeling like people need to walk on eggshells around you. And these misconceptions treat our sensitivity like a character floor
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Have you ever been told that you're too sensitive or that you just shouldn't think so much? You're overreacting to something so small. You let the world hurt you or my all-time favorite. You just take everything so personally. If you are, you're overreacting to something so small, you're overreacting to something so small. You let the world hurt you or my all-time favorite. You just take everything so personally. If you are, if you are, are a highly sensitive person, these statements are definitely something that you've probably encountered and are most likely sick of hearing. Being a highly sensitive person is so much more than what people think it is. There is such a limited idea that if you're sensitive, you must cry all the time, you ever react, you take things too seriously, that you make it difficult for others. Sensitivity is often synonymous with fragility, being easy to break and feeling like people need to walk on eggshells around you. And these misconceptions treat our sensitivity like a character floor|||欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里参加另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十岁的心理学。你有没有被告知过你太敏感了，或者你只是不应该想太多？你对这么小的事情反应过度了。你让世界伤害了你，或者我最喜欢的。你总是把什么都当作针对个人。如果你是，你对这么小的事情反应过度了，你对这么小的事情反应过度了。你让世界伤害了你，或者我最喜欢的。你总是把什么都当作针对个人。如果你是，如果你是一个高度敏感的人，这些话你肯定遇到过，并且很可能已经听腻了。作为一个高度敏感的人，远比人们想象的要复杂得多。有一种非常局限的想法，认为如果你敏感，你就一定会一直哭泣，你总是反应过度，你把事情看得太严重，以至于给别人添麻烦。敏感往往是脆弱的同义词，很容易破碎，让人觉得别人需要在你身边如履薄冰。这些误解将我们的敏感视作一种性格缺陷
when in fact being a deeply sensitive, gentle, feeling person simply means that you have a profound and rich inner emotional life that causes you to see, feel, perceive the world differently and with more colour and complexity. Everything is just heightened. The beautiful things about the world are magnified, but so is a lot of the pain and the stress. and the sadness.
when in fact being a deeply sensitive, gentle, feeling person simply means that you have a profound and rich inner emotional life that causes you to see, feel, perceive the world differently and with more colour and complexity. Everything is just heightened. The beautiful things about the world are magnified, but so is a lot of the pain and the stress. and the sadness.|||而事实上，作为一个极其敏感、温柔、多情的人，仅仅意味着你拥有一个深厚而丰富的内心情感生活，这使你能够以不同的方式、带着更多的色彩和复杂性来看待、感受和感知世界。一切都被放大了。世界美好的一面被放大了，但许多痛苦、压力和悲伤也是如此。
Sometimes that can be overwhelming, but I honestly think it's better to feel a lot than nothing at all. And, you know, who decided that being overly sensitive is a bad thing in comparison to being insensitive or completely numb to what you're experiencing? In my mind, there's one of those that is most certainly a better option. So today we are going to discuss what it means to be a highly sensitive person, breaking down some of the myths and the misconceptions that others might have.
Sometimes that can be overwhelming, but I honestly think it's better to feel a lot than nothing at all. And, you know, who decided that being overly sensitive is a bad thing in comparison to being insensitive or completely numb to what you're experiencing? In my mind, there's one of those that is most certainly a better option. So today we are going to discuss what it means to be a highly sensitive person, breaking down some of the myths and the misconceptions that others might others might have.|||有时这可能会让人难以承受，但老实说，我觉得感受很多总比什么都感觉不到要好。而且，你知道的，与麻木不仁或对你的经历完全麻木相比，是谁决定了过度敏感是一件坏事？在我看来，其中有一个无疑是更好的选择。所以今天我们将讨论成为一个高度敏感的人意味着什么，打破其他人可能有的迷思和误解。
We're also going to explore what actually makes us sensitive on a genetic level, on a parental level, on a childhood level, the hidden powers and hidden talents of sensitive people when it comes to intelligence, creativity, empathy, how to help people understand you more as a highly sensitive person, and kind of just having an overall conversation. around how to make your sensitivity fit into the world, how to make the world make space for you as a sensitive person, and why the world should be doing that, why we need highly sensitive people
We're also going to explore what actually makes us sensitive on a genetic level, on a parental level, on a childhood level, the hidden powers and hidden talents of sensitive people when it comes to intelligence, creativity, empathy, how to help people understand you more as a highly sensitive person, and kind of just having an overall conversation. around how to make your sensitivity fit into the world, how to make the world make space for you as a sensitive person, and why the world should be doing that, why we need highly sensitive people|||我们还将探讨是什么在基因层面、父母层面、童年层面上让我们变得敏感，敏感之人在智力、创造力、同理心方面的隐藏力量和隐藏天赋，如何帮助人们作为高度敏感的人更多地理解你，以及进行一次全面的对话，探讨如何让你的敏感适应这个世界，如何让世界为作为一个敏感的人的你腾出空间，以及为什么世界应该这样做，为什么我们需要高度敏感的人
like you and I to keep the world spinning, to keep people feeling, to bring empathy and intelligence and a certain emotional vividness to situations that other people might not bring those things. So there is so much in this episode that I think might surprise you. So many studies, research papers, fun facts that will hopefully allow you to know your own self even better as someone who is deeply feeling, as someone who is very in tune with the world and everything going on around them. Because I just feel like highly sensitive people deserve to be seen. They deserve to feel acknowledged. They are some of the best people in the world. So I want to make some space for them on this podcast and just talk about it with you guys today. So
like you and I to keep the world spinning, to keep people feeling, to bring empathy and intelligence and a certain emotional vividness to situations that other people might not bring those things. So there is so much in this episode that I think might surprise you. So many studies, research papers, fun facts that will hopefully allow you to know your own self even better as someone who is deeply feeling, as someone who is very in tune with the world and everything going on around them. Because I just feel like highly sensitive people deserve to be seen. They deserve to feel acknowledged. They are some of the best people in the world. So I want to make some space for them on this podcast and just talk about it with you guys today. So|||像你我这样的人来让世界运转，让人们保持感受，为其他人可能无法带来这些东西的情境带来同理心、智慧和某种情感生动性。所以本期节目中有很多内容我想会让你感到惊讶。如此多的研究、研究论文、趣事，希望能够让你更了解自己，作为一个情感深刻的人，作为一个与世界以及周围发生的一切非常合拍的人。因为我只是觉得高度敏感的人值得被看见。他们值得被认可。他们是世界上最好的一些人。所以我希望在这个播客中为他们腾出一些空间，今天就和大家聊聊这个。所以
there is so much on the agenda. I'm going to stop babbling. And without further ado, let's get into the psychology of highly sensitive people and kind of answering that question, am I just too sensitive? So starting off strong, what are the actual characteristics of a highly sensitive person in comparison to someone who is, I don't know, of regular sensitivity? I don't know if it's regular. Let's just say average. With everything, what makes someone sensitive, what makes something anything really varies. It's probably worth noting that there are two different types of sensitivity. There is reactive or environmental sensitivity and personality or internal sensitivity.
there is so much on the agenda. I'm going to stop babbling. And without further ado, let's get into the psychology of highly sensitive people and kind of answering that question, am I just too sensitive? So starting off strong, what are the actual characteristics of a highly sensitive person in comparison to someone who is, I don't know, of regular sensitivity? I don't know if it's regular. Let's just say average. With everything, what makes someone sensitive, what makes something anything really varies. It's probably worth noting that there are two different types of sensitivity. There is reactive or environmental sensitivity and personality or internal sensitivity.|||日程上有很多事情。我不废话了。废话少说，让我们进入高度敏感者的心理学，并回答那个问题：我是不是太敏感了？那么先声夺人，与我不知道的具有常规敏感度的人相比，高度敏感者的实际特征是什么？我不知道这算不算常规。我们暂且称之为平均水平。对于一切事物，是什么让人敏感，是什么让任何东西变得敏感，其实都因人而异。可能值得注意的是，有两种不同类型的敏感。一种是反应型或环境型敏感，另一种是人格型或内在型敏感。
We all have times when we're just a little bit on edge and we're a little bit fragile, like when we're tired or when our hormones are fluctuating, when our, anxiety is biking because of, you know, a really stressful period in our lives. These are all incredibly taxing experiences and emotional states that are going to put a strain on our limited cognitive and mental resources. That is why we are so sensitive during those times in particular, because we genuinely just have less energy in the tank to self-regulate and to process our emotions. So that is environmental or reactive sensitivity.
We all have times when we're just a little bit on edge and we're a little bit fragile, like when we're tired or when our hormones are fluctuating, when our, anxiety is biking because of, you know, a really stressful period in our lives. These are all incredibly taxing experiences and emotional states that are going to put a strain on our limited cognitive and mental resources. That is why we are so sensitive during those times in particular, because we genuinely just have less energy in the tank to self-regulate and to process our emotions. So that is environmental or reactive sensitivity.|||我们都有过情绪有点紧绷、有点脆弱的时候，比如当我们累了，或者荷尔蒙波动时，当我们的焦虑因为生活中真正压力重重的时期而飙升时。这些都是极其消耗精力的经历和情绪状态，会给我们有限的认知和心理资源带来压力正因如此，我们在那些时期尤其敏感，因为我们油箱里的能量确实更少了，无法自我调节和处理我们的情绪。这就是环境或反应型敏感。
The opposite of this is internal personality, longstanding trait sensitivity. This is the kind of hypersensitivity that is part of who we are, part of our personality. These are the people who we would call highly sensitive persons, HSPs. It literally has an acronym. And this was a term that was coined by the psychologist Elaine Aaron in the 90s. And she wrote probably one of the most in-depth books on this titled very appropriately. It's called the highly sensitive person. That is when this experience, this personality trait, this phenomena first got a name.
The opposite of this is internal personality, longstanding trait sensitivity. This is the kind of hypersensitivity that is part of who we are, part of our personality. These are the people who we would call highly sensitive persons, HSPs. It literally has an acronym. And this was a term that was coined by the psychologist Elaine Aaron in the 90s. And she wrote probably one of the most in-depth books on this titled very appropriately. It's called the highly sensitive person. That is when this experience, this personality trait, this phenomena first got a name.|||与此相反的是内在人格、长期存在的特质敏感性。这就是那种作为我们一部分、作为我们人格一部分的高度敏感。这些人就是我们所说的高度敏感人群（HSP）。它甚至有一个缩写。这是心理学家伊莱恩·阿伦（Elaine Aaron）在 90 年代创造的一个术语。她写了一本关于这个主题的最深入的书，书名非常贴切。它叫做《高度敏感的人》。就在那时，这种经历、这种人格特质、这种现象第一次拥有了名字。
She was the one who began to really observe it, began to draw patterns between people who were all expressing the same reactions and feelings and behaviors. And she labeled those people highly sensitive persons. She also went on to develop a questionnaire that can help people like you and I basically confirm or identify themselves as highly sensitive people. And it's called the highly sensitive person scale. It's free. It's online. It's available to anyone who wants to use it. I'll leave a link in the episode description.
She was the one who began to really observe it, began to draw patterns between people who were all expressing the same reactions and feelings and behaviors. And she labeled those people highly sensitive persons. She also went on to develop a questionnaire that can help people like you and I basically confirm or identify themselves as highly sensitive people. And it's called the highly sensitive person scale. It's free. It's online. It's available to anyone who wants to use it. I'll leave a link in the episode description.|||她是第一个真正开始观察它的人，开始在所有表现出相同反应、感受和行为的人之间找出规律。她将这些人贴上了高度敏感者的标签。她接着开发了一份问卷，可以帮助像你我这样的人基本确认或识别自己是否为高度敏感者。它被称为高度敏感者量表。它是免费的。它在网上。任何想用它的人都可以使用。我会在单集简介中留下链接。
But essentially her assessment requires you to simply check some boxes, check the boxes that apply to you based on the steps. statements that are said and at the end you receive a score. Some of the questions, some of the boxes that you can tick include things like other people's moods affect me deeply. I am easily overwhelmed by strong sensory input, bright lights, strong smells, weird fabrics. I startle easily. I find it hard and overwhelming to have a lot going on at once. I try hard to avoid making mistakes or forgetting things. I get annoyed when people try to get me to do too many things at once. And then there are also criteria like,
But essentially her assessment requires you to simply check some boxes, check the boxes that apply to you based on the steps. statements that are said and at the end you receive a score. Some of the questions, some of the boxes that you can tick include things like other people's moods affect me deeply. I am easily overwhelmed by strong sensory input, bright lights, strong smells, weird fabrics. I startle easily. I find it hard and overwhelming to have a lot going on at once. I try hard to avoid making mistakes or forgetting things. I get annoyed when people try to get me to do too many things at once. And then there are also criteria like,|||但本质上，她的评估要求你只需勾选一些方框，根据所说的陈述勾选适用于你的方框，最后你会得到一个分数。你可以勾选的一些问题和方框包括：别人的情绪深深地影响着我。我很容易被强烈的感官输入、强烈的灯光、强烈的气味、奇怪的面料压垮。我很容易受惊。我发现同时发生很多事情既困难又让我不知所措。我努力避免犯错或忘事。当人们试图让我同时做太多事情时，我会感到恼火。然后还有一些标准，比如，
I am deeply moved by music, movies, and art. I have a rich and complex inner life. When I sense someone is uncomfortable, I tend to know what needs to change in the environment to make them more comfortable, like lighting or needing a pillow, that kind of thing. I think it's really important to highlight those elements of what it means to be a highly sensitive person. Because the misconception is that
I am deeply moved by music, movies, and art. I have a rich and complex inner life. When I sense someone is uncomfortable, I tend to know what needs to change in the environment to make them more comfortable, like lighting or needing a pillow, that kind of thing. I think it's really important to highlight those elements of what it means to be a highly sensitive person. Because the misconception is that|||我被音乐、电影和艺术深深打动。我有着丰富而复杂的内心生活。当我感觉到有人不舒服时，我往往知道环境中需要改变什么才能让他们更舒服，比如照明或需要一个枕头之类的东西。我认为强调作为高度敏感之人的这些要素非常重要。因为误解在于
sensitive people are just too demanding, take things too personally, too highly strong. The truth is is that they are actually highly attuned to others' needs, often deeply empathetic as well, deeply feeling, because they exist so closely with their emotions. Everything is on the surface for them. And so sadness is not just sadness, it's deep sorrow. Happiness is not just happiness, it's pure ecstasy. Everything exists at the highest level for them. That point about being deeply moved by music, movies, art as well, I find that really, really compelling. I actually saw this video from someone the other day who talked about what it's like to be a highly sensitive person watching the Olympics and how it's just like,
sensitive people are just too demanding, take things too personally, too highly strong. The truth is is that they are actually highly attuned to others' needs, often deeply empathetic as well, deeply feeling, because they exist so closely with their emotions. Everything is on the surface for them. And so sadness is not just sadness, it's deep sorrow. Happiness is not just happiness, it's pure ecstasy. Everything exists at the highest level for them. That point about being deeply moved by music, movies, art as well, I find that really, really compelling. I actually saw this video from someone the other day who talked about what it's like to be a highly sensitive person watching the Olympics and how it's just like,|||敏感的人只是太挑剔、太爱对号入座、神经质。事实是，他们实际上对别人的需求高度敏感，通常也具有深刻的同理心，情感深沉，因为他们与自己的情绪紧密相连。一切对他们来说都表露在表面。因此悲伤不仅仅是悲伤，而是深深的哀伤。快乐不仅仅是快乐，而是纯粹的狂喜。对他们来说，一切都存在于最高级别。关于被音乐、电影、艺术深深打动的这一点，我觉得真的非常引人入胜。前几天我实际上看到某人的这个视频，谈到作为一个高度敏感的人看奥运会是什么感觉，以及它是如何感觉像，
constant tears because you feel everything that the athletes are feeling even through the screen. And this just really highlights how human it really is to be highly sensitive, how connected we feel to things around us that are beautiful, that move us, that make us feel something. Why is that the case? It's because of an obscure region of the brain known as the VMPFC. Super random. That's all you need to know. the VMPFC, it's the part of the brain that, among other things, adds emotional resonance to our pure sensory data.
constant tears because you feel everything that the athletes are feeling even through the screen. And this just really highlights how human it really is to be highly sensitive, how connected we feel to things around us that are beautiful, that move us, that make us feel something. Why is that the case? It's because of an obscure region of the brain known as the VMPFC. Super random. That's all you need to know. the VMPFC, it's the part of the brain that, among other things, adds emotional resonance to our pure sensory data.|||眼泪不断，因为即使通过屏幕，你也能感受到运动员们感受到的所有一切。这真正凸显了高度敏感是多么地具有人性，我们与周围美丽的事物、感动我们的事物、让我们有所感触的事物是多么紧密相连。为什么会这样？这是因为大脑中一个鲜为人知的区域，被称为腹内侧前额叶皮层（VMPFC）。超级随机。这就是你需要知道的全部。VMPFC，它是大脑的一部分，除其他功能外，它为我们的纯感官数据增添了情感共鸣。
So, you know, you see a blanket on a couch. If you didn't have your VMPFC, you'd be like, oh, that's just a random blanket. That's it. You don't really have the same emotional attachment to maybe know that that blanket is, you know, the duna that your grandmother made you for your fifth birthday. or, you know, the blanket that you brought to college, that part of our brain that sees things applies meaning to them, applies emotion, history to them. That part of our brain is heightened and more active in people who are highly sensitive. It's why you feel something emotional when you see a flower rather than just seeing a flower.
So, you know, you see a blanket on a couch. If you didn't have your VMPFC, you'd be like, oh, that's just a random blanket. That's it. You don't really have the same emotional attachment to maybe know that that blanket is, you know, the duna that your grandmother made you for your fifth birthday. or, you know, the blanket that you brought to college, that part of our brain that sees things applies meaning to them, applies emotion, history to them. That part of our brain is heightened and more active in people who are highly sensitive. It's why you feel something emotional when you see a flower rather than just seeing a flower.|||所以，你知道的，你看到沙发上有一条毯子。如果你没有 VMPFC，你可能会想，哦，那只是一条随意的毯子。就是这样。你不会真正产生同样的情感依恋，可能不知道那条毯子是，你知道的，你外祖母为你五岁生日做的羽绒被。或者，你知道的，你带去大学的毯子，我们大脑中看到事物并为其赋予意义、赋予情感、历史的那部分。高度敏感之人的大脑的这一部分得到增强且更加活跃。这就是为什么当你看到一朵花时，你会感受到某种情感，而不仅仅是看到一朵花。
This also means that people who are highly sensitive, they experience. the world with a greater level of emotional saturation, more color, essentially, more vividness. And that can also make us more creative. One study from NYU found in, I think it was 2017, that higher sensitivity to our environment, highly sensitive people, also show higher emotional intelligence, greater emotional sensitivity, and all of that is correlated with higher scores on a creativity test. It all kind of comes together, right? Having that real sense of our emotions,
This also means that people who are highly sensitive, they experience. the world with a greater level of emotional saturation, more color, essentially, more vividness. And that can also make us more creative. One study from NYU found in, I think it was 2017, that higher sensitivity to our environment, highly sensitive people, also show higher emotional intelligence, greater emotional sensitivity, and all of that is correlated with higher scores on a creativity test. It all kind of comes together, right? Having that real sense of our emotions,|||这也意味着高度敏感的人，他们体验世界时带有更高水平的情感饱和度，本质上是更多的色彩、更多的生动性。这也可以使我们更具创造力。纽约大学（NYU）在 2017 年的一项研究发现，对环境更高的敏感度、高度敏感的人，也表现出更高的情商、更大的情感敏感度，所有这些都与创造力测试的更高得分相关。这一切都融为一体了，对吧？对我们的情感有那种真实的感知，
feeling like you can reach out and touch them also means that you can see those emotions in other people, and it also means that you can take those emotions and funnel them into other activities, funnel them into a beautiful form like making art. And I really want that nuance to come through here. This is not a one-dimensional experience, only defined by feeling overwhelmed, only defined by crying all the time or needing space, needing distance.
feeling like you can reach out and touch them also means that you can see those emotions in other people, and it also means that you can take those emotions and funnel them into other activities, funnel them into a beautiful form like making art. And I really want that nuance to come through here. This is not a one-dimensional experience, only defined by feeling overwhelmed, only defined by crying all the time or needing space, needing distance.|||感觉你可以伸手去触摸它们，这也意味着你可以在其他人身上看到这些情绪，这也意味着你可以吸收这些情绪并将其引导到其他活动中，将其引导到像艺术创作这样美丽的形式中。我非常希望这里的细微差别能体现出来。这不是一种单一维度的体验，不仅仅由不知所措的感觉定义，不仅仅由一直哭泣或需要空间、需要距离定义。
It is a vivid, emotional and sensory state that brings more color, movement, light, excitement to the world. It sounds like a good thing, but that can also be really, really overwhelming. So highly sensitive people are thought to make up roughly 20% of the general population, which is probably higher than we would expect. Obviously, with everything, it's a bit of a spectrum, but again, about one and five of us have the kind of brain, have the kind of emotional regulation system that notices just a little bit more about the world around us, that is just a little bit more impacted by others' feelings
It is a vivid, emotional and sensory state that brings more color, movement, light, excitement to the world. It sounds like a good thing, but that can also be really, really overwhelming. So highly sensitive people are thought to make up roughly 20% of the general population, which is probably higher than we would expect. Obviously, with everything, it's a bit of a spectrum, but again, about one and five of us have the kind of brain, have the kind of emotional regulation system that notices just a little bit more about the world around us, that is just a little bit more impacted by others' feelings|||它是一种生动的、情感的和感官的状态，为世界带来更多的色彩、运动、光线和兴奋。这听起来像是一件好事，但这也可能真的非常令人不知所措。因此，据信高度敏感的人约占总人口的 20%，这可能比我们预期的要高。显然，对于一切事物来说，这都有点像一个光谱，但同样，我们当中大约有五分之一的人拥有那种大脑，拥有那种情感调节系统，能够对我们周围的世界注意到更多一点，受他人感觉的影响也多一点
and also our own. An interesting, fun fact, humans are not the only species that can be classified or defined as highly sensitive. Elephants, for example, dolphins, horses, octopuses, they all show varying degrees of emotional and social sensitivity between them. What's something that those animals all have in common? They're also very, very smart and they're very highly evolved compared to your average reptile or mammal or marsupial, which goes to show that the more connections in our brain, the more neurons, the more intelligent we are, perhaps the more capacity we have to be sensitive creatures. That might explain why, according to recent research by the University of Berkeley,
and also our own. An interesting, fun fact, humans are not the only species that can be classified or defined as highly sensitive. Elephants, for example, dolphins, horses, octopuses, they all show varying degrees of emotional and social sensitivity between them. What's something that those animals all have in common? They're also very, very smart and they're very highly evolved compared to your average reptile or mammal or marsupial, which goes to show that the more connections in our brain, the more neurons, the more intelligent we are, perhaps the more capacity we have to be sensitive creatures. That might explain why, according to recent research by the University of Berkeley,|||以及我们自己的。一个有趣的趣事，人类并不是唯一可以被分类或定义为高度敏感的物种。例如大象、海豚、马、章鱼，它们之间都表现出不同程度的情感和社会敏感性。这些动物有什么共同点？与一般的爬行动物、哺乳动物或有袋动物相比，它们也非常非常聪明，并且进化程度很高，这表明我们大脑中的连接越多，神经元越多，我们就越聪明，也许我们作为敏感生物的能力就越强。这或许可以解释为什么根据伯克利大学的最新研究，
highly sensitive people often have higher IQs, not just. EQs. They also are higher in a particular kind of intelligence called sensory intelligence. Basically, we process information more deeply. We find that we reflect longer on our experiences. We notice kind of subtle details were more affected by them. We draw links between more of our experiences. There was a recent article published by Psychology Today. Actually, it was published just last year. It's funny. The magazine is called Psychology Today, but the article within it published last year. Don't know if that needed clarification, but you got it anyways. And this article linked sensitivity to brilliance. You need to be smart to be as reactive or perceptive of your
highly sensitive people often have higher IQs, not just. EQs. They also are higher in a particular kind of intelligence called sensory intelligence. Basically, we process information more deeply. We find that we reflect longer on our experiences. We notice kind of subtle details were more affected by them. We draw links between more of our experiences. There was a recent article published by Psychology Today. Actually, it was published just last year. It's funny. The magazine is called Psychology Today, but the article within it published last year. Don't know if that needed clarification, but you got it anyways. And this article linked sensitivity to brilliance. You need to be smart to be as reactive or perceptive of your|||高度敏感的人往往拥有更高的智商，不仅仅是情商。他们在一种被称为感官智力的特殊智力上也更高。基本上，我们更深入地处理信息。我们发现我们对经历的反思时间更长。我们注意到微妙的细节并受其影响更大。我们在更多的经历之间建立联系。《今日心理学》最近发表了一篇文章。事实上，它就在去年发表的。很有趣。这本杂志叫《今日心理学》，但其中的文章是去年发表的。不知道这是否需要澄清，但反正你已经知道了。这篇文章将敏感性与才华联系起来。你需要足够聪明，才能对你的
environment as your sensitivity makes you. You cannot be a dumb, highly sensitive person. That's basically what this article was saying. It's kind of a consolation prize. You know, like, yes, I find it hard to not break down, but at least I might be a genius or I might be a creative prodigy. I would love to hear from you guys. If you are someone who is highly sensitive, do you do something that requires you to use your more creative side of your brain? Or do you do something that is like someone perceived as like a highly emotional career, like a therapist, like a psychologist, just like maybe even a primary school teacher, a kindergarten teacher. I really want to know because I feel like that would be very, very interesting to see.
environment as your sensitivity makes you. You cannot be a dumb, highly sensitive person. That's basically what this article was saying. It's kind of a consolation prize. You know, like, yes, I find it hard to not break down, but at least I might be a genius or I might be a creative prodigy. I would love to hear from you guys. If you are someone who is highly sensitive, do you do something that requires you to use your more creative side of your brain? Or do you do something that is like someone perceived as like a highly emotional career, like a therapist, like a psychologist, just like maybe even a primary school teacher, a kindergarten teacher. I really want to know because I feel like that would be very, very interesting to see.|||环境做出如此反应或感知，这正是你的敏感性所赋予你的。你不可能是一个愚蠢的高度敏感的人。这基本上就是这篇文章所说的。这算是一种安慰奖吧。你知道的，就像，是的，我发现自己很难不崩溃，但至少我可能是一个天才，或者我可能是一个创作神童。我很想听听大家的意见。如果你是一个高度敏感的人，你会做一些需要你使用大脑更有创造力的一面事情吗？或者你做的事就像别人认为的那样，是一份高度情感化的职业，比如治疗师、心理学家，甚至可能是小学老师、幼儿园老师。我真的很想知道，因为我觉得这会非常非常有趣。
So we spend a little bit of time in kind of what makes a highly sensitive person the criteria, the characteristics. How does it happen? How do we become this way? What actually contributes to this unique way of seeing the world? It's a couple of things. Let's start with the big one. The big one is our innate temperament.
So we spend a little bit of time in kind of what makes a highly sensitive person the criteria, the characteristics. How does it happen? How do we become this way? What actually contributes to this unique way of seeing the world? It's a couple of things. Let's start with the big one. The big one is our innate temperament.|||因此，我们花了一点时间来探讨是什么构成了一个高度敏感的人的标准和特征。这是怎么发生的？我们是怎么变成这样的？究竟是什么促成了这种独特的看世界的方式？有几件事情。让我们从最大的一个开始。最大的是我们与生俱来的气质。
Now, temperament exists like one step back from personality. Temperament is the nature that we were born with. You and I most likely have had the same temperament since we were just little kids. If you hear a parent say, you know, oh, my child is just so calm and curious or, yeah, my new baby is so fussy and so short-tempered, they're probably not wrong. that kind of personality that a child has contributes to our future personality because it's our temperament. And the temperament of highly sensitive people, there's four different types of temperaments. The one that highly sensitive people most often sit in is the melancholic temperament. Melancholic people are more reserved, they're more thoughtful, analytical, but also deeply feeling.
Now, temperament exists like one step back from personality. Temperament is the nature that we were born with. You and I most likely have had the same temperament since we were just little kids. If you hear a parent say, you know, oh, my child is just so calm and curious or, yeah, my new baby is so fussy and so short-tempered, they're probably not wrong. that kind of personality that a child has contributes to our future personality because it's our temperament. And the temperament of highly sensitive people, there's four different types of temperaments. The one that highly sensitive people most often sit in is the melancholic temperament. Melancholic people are more reserved, they're more thoughtful, analytical, but also deeply feeling.|||现在，气质的存在就像比人格退后了一步。气质是我们生来就有的天性。你和我从小到大很可能拥有相同的气质。如果你听到一位父母说，你知道的，哦，我的孩子太冷静、太好奇了，或者，是的，我的新宝宝太挑剔、脾气太急躁了，他们可能没有说错。孩子拥有的这种性格有助于我们未来的性格，因为它是我们的气质。高度敏感之人的气质，有四种不同的气质类型。高度敏感之人最常处于的那一种是忧郁质。忧郁质的人比较内向，比较深思熟虑、善于分析，但也情感深沉。
Sometimes that can be confused with anxiety. People with a melancholic temperament are also highly empathetic. And we know that being an empath and being highly sensitive often comes hand in hand. Because as someone with high empathy, you are naturally going to feel subtle changes in people and your environment. You pick up on those invisible cues that others may not. You notice when someone is suddenly... going quiet and you absorb the feelings and the emotional states of those around you, which is what makes you so reactive to them.
Sometimes that can be confused with anxiety. People with a melancholic temperament are also highly empathetic. And we know that being an empath and being highly sensitive often comes hand in hand. Because as someone with high empathy, you are naturally going to feel subtle changes in people and your environment. You pick up on those invisible cues that others may not. You notice when someone is suddenly... going quiet and you absorb the feelings and the emotional states of those around you, which is what makes you so reactive to them.|||有时这会与焦虑混淆。忧郁质气质的人也具有高度的同理心。我们知道，具有同理心和高度敏感往往是齐头并进的。因为作为一个具有高同理心的人，你自然会感受到人际和环境中的微妙变化。你会捕捉到别人可能捕捉不到的无形线索。当有人突然变得安静时，你会注意到，你会吸收周围人的感受和情绪状态，这就是为什么你对他们的反应如此强烈。
Because once you've had that intuition that this is how someone's feeling, it can be difficult not to respond, not to want to fix it, not to want to reduce the discomfort, not just for yourself, but for others as well. This really explains why one of the criteria for being a highly sensitive person is needing more downtime, needing more time to decompress after those big social days, after being around people for so long. Because you're probably freaking exhausted if you've spent all those hours, literally just absorbing everybody else's feelings, taking on all of that,
Because once you've had that intuition that this is how someone's feeling, it can be difficult not to respond, not to want to fix it, not to want to reduce the discomfort, not just for yourself, but for others as well. This really explains why one of the criteria for being a highly sensitive person is needing more downtime, needing more time to decompress after those big social days, after being around people for so long. Because you're probably freaking exhausted if you've spent all those hours, literally just absorbing everybody else's feelings, taking on all of that,|||因为一旦你有了这种直觉，觉得某人是这种感觉，就很难不去做出反应，不想去解决它，不想去减少不适感，不仅为了你自己，也为了别人。这真正解释了为什么成为高度敏感之人的标准之一是需要更多停机时间，在经历了那些重大的社交日子之后，在与人相处了这么长时间之后，需要更多的时间来解压。因为如果你花了那么多小时，字面上只是吸收了其他所有人的感受，承担了所有这些，你可能会筋疲力尽，
trying to mediate and manage how other people are coping, as well as how you're coping on the inside, what you're actually feeling. Like, it's incredibly draining, I think, to be that alert, even if it's not something that you're consciously doing. So temperament is one of the first factors that just contributes to you being an innately sensitive person. Another factor at play, though, is, of course, genetics. So there is a developmental psychologist at Queen Mary University of London, Dr. Michael
trying to mediate and manage how other people are coping, as well as how you're coping on the inside, what you're actually feeling. Like, it's incredibly draining, I think, to be that alert, even if it's not something that you're consciously doing. So temperament is one of the first factors that just contributes to you being an innately sensitive person. Another factor at play, though, is, of course, genetics. So there is a developmental psychologist at Queen Mary University of London, Dr. Michael|||试图调解和管理其他人是如何应对的，以及你在内心是如何应对的，你实际上的感受是什么。就像，保持那种高度警惕令人难以置信地消耗精力，我认为，即使这不是你有意在做的事情。所以气质是导致你成为一个天生敏感的人的首要因素之一。不过，另一个起作用的因素当然是基因。因此，伦敦玛丽女王大学有一位发展心理学家，迈克尔博士
pluis and he is the one who has done a lot of research into this. He basically is suggested that your genes account for 47% of how sensitive you are, nearly half. How he found this out, he looked at twins, and he looked at twins who, basically he was like, okay, if I get two twins here and one of them is highly sensitive, what are the chances that the other one's going to be highly sensitive as well? And the chance was around 50%. And so that's how he kind of did. that that was the genetic influence behind this trait, behind this experience. The rest is environment. We're going to get to that in a second. But the genetic blueprint that we receive from our parents is basically going to determine so much about who we become and who we
pluis and he is the one who has done a lot of research into this. He basically is suggested that your genes account for 47% of how sensitive you are, nearly half. How he found this out, he looked at twins, and he looked at twins who, basically he was like, okay, if I get two twins here and one of them is highly sensitive, what are the chances that the other one's going to be highly sensitive as well? And the chance was around 50%. And so that's how he kind of did. that that was the genetic influence behind this trait, behind this experience. The rest is environment. We're going to get to that in a second. But the genetic blueprint that we receive from our parents is basically going to determine so much about who we become and who we|||普鲁伊斯（Pluess），他一直在对此进行大量研究。他基本上提出，你的基因占你敏感程度的 47%，将近一半。他是如何发现这一点的呢，他研究了双胞胎，他研究的双胞胎是，基本上他想，好吧，如果我这里有一对双胞胎，其中一个是高度敏感的，另一个也是高度敏感的几率是多少？几率大约是 50%。所以他是这样做的。这就是这一特质、这一经历背后的基因影响。其余的都是环境。我们一会儿会讲到这一点。但我们从父母那里得到的基因蓝图基本上将决定关于我们成为什么样的人以及我们
become as a sensitive individual. It's going to determine our threshold for simulation. It's going to really help determine our anxiety levels, our attentional systems, our level of alertness, all of which contribute, I guess you can guess it, to hypersensitivity. There is not just one gene at play here, though. There's not just a single gene. If it's flipped or not, if it's switched or not, that's going to determine whether you emerge as a highly sensitive person. There's actually three genes, the sensitivity gene, the dopamine gene, and the emotional
become as a sensitive individual. It's going to determine our threshold for simulation. It's going to really help determine our anxiety levels, our attentional systems, our level of alertness, all of which contribute, I guess you can guess it, to hypersensitivity. There is not just one gene at play here, though. There's not just a single gene. If it's flipped or not, if it's switched or not, that's going to determine whether you emerge as a highly sensitive person. There's actually three genes, the sensitivity gene, the dopamine gene, and the emotional|||作为一个敏感个体将成为什么样的人的很多事情。它将决定我们对模拟的阈值。它将真正有助于决定我们的焦虑水平、我们的注意力系统、我们的警觉水平，我猜你可以猜到，所有这些都有助于导致高度敏感。不过，这里起作用的不止一个基因。不仅仅是单一基因。它是否被翻转，是否被切换，将决定你是否作为一个高度敏感的人出现。实际上有三个基因，敏感基因、多巴胺基因和情感
vividness gene. So let's start off with the sensitivity gene first. Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Crave Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse.
vividness gene. So let's start off with the sensitivity gene first. Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Crave, Netflix, and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse.|||生动性基因。那么我们首先从敏感基因开始。获取 Bell 纯光纤网络，搭配 Crave、Netflix 和 Disney Plus，每月 94 加元起。两年期网络且开通自动付款优惠的两年价格保证。访问 bell.ca 了解详情并查看可用性。Bell，连接就是一切.我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。每周，新闻都变得更糟。
The world gets crazier and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'ma check you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm gonna play you. Join Yamanika Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast. You're the problem with Yamanika. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the Dear Chelsea Network.
The world gets crazier and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'ma check you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm gonna play you. Join Yamanika Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast. You're the problem with Yamanika. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the Dear Chelsea Network.|||世界变得越来越疯狂，亚曼尼卡在这里告诉任何负责人，你才是问题所在。如果你来这里玩游戏，我会检查你的。好吗？如果你在新闻中做了一些听起来不好的事情，我会对你不客气。加入亚曼尼卡·桑德斯（Yamanika Saunders），她在她的新播客中剖析本周最具问题的故事。亚曼尼卡带你了解《你才是问题所在》。你知道我刚刚发现西德妮·斯威尼是谁吗？每周三更新新节目，作为我的新网络“亲爱的切尔西网络”的一部分。
If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. So join Yamanika. each episode as she answers one question. Who's the problem? I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. So join Yamanika. each episode as she answers one question. Who's the problem? I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,|||如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好或者做得少一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。所以加入亚曼尼卡的节目。每一集她都会回答一个问题。谁是问题所在？我是亚曼尼卡，我先走了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 上收听亚曼尼卡的《你才是问题所在》，
or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Tatoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast,
or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Tatoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast,|||或任何你获取播客的地方。我是尼克·塔托罗。你可能从《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》中认识我。但我也是来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。在我的新播客中，
delivering happiness with Nick Titoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street Pizza to a new guest. deliver pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Titoro. It's called happiness. Delivering happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh my God. And many, many more. Open your free high heart radio apps.
delivering happiness with Nick Titoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street Pizza to a new guest. deliver pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Titoro. It's called happiness. Delivering happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh my God. And many, many more. Open your free high heart radio apps.|||由尼克·蒂托罗主持的《传递幸福》，我将把王子街披萨的披萨送到一位新嘉宾手中。现在送披萨？然后我们坐下来进行真正的对话。我与从赛斯·罗林斯的每个人分享过一块披萨。你在对我的腰带做什么？到亚历克斯·罗德里格斯。只想让你们知道，我们在这里和其中一位传奇人物交谈。到比尔·伯尔。我想我从来没见过像我这样完全精神错乱的人。现在我们甚至有更多伟大的嘉宾登场，包括伟大的约翰·蒂托罗。这叫幸福。传递幸福。马里亚诺·里维拉。哦，天哪。还有很多很多。打开你的免费 IHeart Radio 应用程序。
Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Detourl. And listen now. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and I heart women's sports.
Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Detourl. And listen now. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and I heart women's sports.|||搜索 Nick Detourl 主持的《传递幸福》。立即收听。大家好，家人们？我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯。嘿，大家好？我是你们的女孩萨姆·J。我们是《每个人都看女子体育》的主持人，这是 Together 和 I heart 女子体育的全新播客。
Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo roer to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is, like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating? The highlights, the rival. Rees, the breakout stars, the moments to take over your entire timeline.
Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo roer to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is, like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating? The highlights, the rival. Rees, the breakout stars, the moments to take over your entire timeline.|||因为说实话。这些天女子体育给我们带来了太多的话题。凯尔西·芬勒（Kelsey Finler），她成为了第一位从加利福尼亚独自划船去夏威夷的女性划船手。我的第一想法是，零食怎么说？比如，我们在吃什么？精彩集锦、竞争。里斯，崭露头角的新星，接管你整个时间线的时刻。
And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out, she beat. Sabalinka. Shout out to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi. You get the palm for that. Because we're not just interested in what happened.
And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out, she beat. Sabalinka. Shout out to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi. You get the palm for that. Because we're not just interested in what happened.|||以及在比赛期间开始并且不知何故持续了一整周的对话。每周，我们都在剖析女子体育界最大的故事。大坂直美表现出色，她击败了萨巴伦卡。向你致敬，娜奥米。你拿下了奖品，娜奥米。你因此获得了奖品。因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣。
We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you're get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us, or rather you know them.
We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you're get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us, or rather you know them.|||我们对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都看女子体育。收听《每个人都看女子体育》。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 或任何你获取播客的地方。嘿，波特兰迪亚的粉丝们。我是凯莉·布朗斯坦和弗雷德·阿米森。你们认识我们，或者更确切地说你们认识他们。
Tony and Candice, Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, the chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week, we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love
Tony and Candice, Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, the chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week, we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love|||托尼和坎迪斯、妮娜和兰斯、斯派克，还有那只鸡。这些年来我们扮演过许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以我们自己的身份出现，来向大家介绍我们的全新播客《波特兰迪亚》AEO 重看版。每周，我们将从头开始重温《波特兰迪亚》的一集，剖析小品，探索我们最具标志性角色的背景故事，重访你熟悉和喜爱的波特兰地点
and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin,
and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin,|||并坦诚我们的创作过程。这一切是怎么制作出来的？为什么我们认为这是一个好主意？我们准备好谈论它了。我们还将邀请那些帮助将其变为现实的人们加入我们。客串明星、合作者和朋友，包括导演乔纳森·克里塞尔、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦、
legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody. Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody. Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||传奇音乐家艾米·曼恩等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥了，不仅是台词，还有一首歌、一段旋律。嗯，我以为他会写。我以为你们都会写一首歌。我记得你当时是这么想的。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何您获取播客的地方收听《波特兰迪亚》Ayo 重看版。
The sensitivity gene is also known as the serotonin gene, and it controls how serotonin is transported in the brain. Serotonin is what helps balance our mood. People who are highly sensitive often have a gene variant that means they have less serotonin available in their brain. Less serotonin. What does that normally mean? Less mood stabilization. Less capacity to regulate your emotional response to what's going on around you and within you.
The sensitivity gene is also known as the serotonin gene, and it controls how serotonin is transported in the brain. Serotonin is what helps balance our mood. People who are highly sensitive often have a gene variant that means they have less serotonin available in their brain. Less serotonin. What does that normally mean? Less mood stabilization. Less capacity to regulate your emotional response to what's going on around you and within you.|||敏感基因也被称为血清素基因，它控制血清素在脑内的运输。血清素是有助于平衡我们情绪的物质。高度敏感的人通常有一种基因变异，这意味着他们大脑中可用的血清素较少。血清素较少。这通常意味着什么？情绪稳定度降低。调节你对周围发生的事情以及你内心发生的事情的情绪反应的能力降低。
The second gene is somewhat similar. It's the dopamine gene. A lot of us see dopamine as simply the happy chemical. It's the chemical that keeps us bright and bubbly and cheery. And to an extent you'd be right. But the reason it makes us so happy is because it makes us feel rewarded by external stimuli. When that gene is mutated or when it varies, it can make it so that we are almost overflowing with dopamine and a bunch of other neurochemicals in response to our environment.
The second gene is somewhat similar. It's the dopamine gene. A lot of us see dopamine as simply the happy chemical. It's the chemical that keeps us bright and bubbly and cheery. And to an extent you'd be right. But the reason it makes us so happy is because it makes us feel rewarded by external stimuli. When that gene is mutated or when it varies, it can make it so that we are almost overflowing with dopamine and a bunch of other neurochemicals in response to our environment.|||第二个基因有些类似。它是多巴胺基因。我们许多人将多巴胺简单地视为快乐化学物质。它是让我们保持明亮、活泼和愉悦的化学物质。在某种程度上你是对的。但它让我们如此快乐的原因是，它让我们感受到来自外部刺激的奖赏。当该基因发生突变或变异时，它会使我们在对环境做出反应时，几乎充满了多巴胺和一堆其他神经化学物质。
Meaning that there's just almost too much. Our brain just can't cope. Everything is a bit unbalanced. And so we don't get the same leveled, sense of reward or reinforcement from things that other people do, like bright lights, like busy environments, like loud pumping music, like intense smells. It just all feels quite messy in our brains. It just feels quite overwhelming because there's just actually too much going on for your brain to really put together. But it also sometimes feels really beautiful.
Meaning that there's just almost too much. Our brain just can't cope. Everything is a bit unbalanced. And so we don't get the same leveled, sense of reward or reinforcement from things that other people do, like bright lights, like busy environments, like loud pumping music, like intense smells. It just all feels quite messy in our brains. It just feels quite overwhelming because there's just actually too much going on for your brain to really put together. But it also sometimes feels really beautiful.|||这意味着几乎太多了。我们的大脑简直无法应付。一切都有点失衡。因此，对于别人做的事情，我们无法获得同样水平的奖励感或强化感，比如强烈的灯光、忙碌的环境、震耳欲聋的音乐、强烈的气味。这一切在我们的大脑中感觉相当凌乱。感觉相当不知所措，因为实际上有太多事情发生，让你的大脑无法真正组合在一起。但有时它也感觉真的很美妙。
If you've got this dysregulated dopamine system, yes, it does mean that, you know, things feel overwhelming at times, but it's also why we feel so moved by things that others might not, and moved by things that other people don't appreciate, like a beautiful view, like a flower, like a TV commercial. Finally, we have the emotional vividness gene. Goes without saying, but I'll say it anyway, most highly sensitive people are keenly aware that they have stronger emotional reactions than others, and they often notice those emotional undercurrents in other people. You pick it all up, you pick up what everybody else is putting down silently, unconsciously, implicitly. If you're highly sensitive, this is not your imagination.
If you've got this dysregulated dopamine system, yes, it does mean that, you know, things feel overwhelming at times, but it's also why we feel so moved by things that others might not, and moved by things that other people don't appreciate, like a beautiful view, like a flower, like a TV commercial. Finally, we have the emotional vividness gene. Goes without saying, but I'll say it anyway, most highly sensitive people are keenly aware that they have stronger emotional reactions than others, and they often notice those emotional undercurrents in other people. You pick it all up, you pick up what everybody else is putting down silently, unconsciously, implicitly. If you're highly sensitive, this is not your imagination.|||如果你有这个失调的多巴胺系统，是的，这意味着，你知道的，有时事情会让人觉得无法承受，但这也是为什么我们会对别人可能不会感动的事情感到如此感动，并被其他人不欣赏的事物所感动，比如美丽的景色、一朵花、一个电视广告。最后，我们有情感生动性基因。不用说，但我还是要说，大多数高度敏感的人都敏锐地意识到他们比其他人有更强的情绪反应，他们经常注意到其他人身上的那些情绪暗流。你把这一切都吸收了，你吸收了其他所有人默默地、无意识地、含蓄地放下的一切。如果你高度敏感，这不是你的想象。
You actually have a brighter palette of emotional colors, so to speak, because of a variant in a gene that controls how our body's stress response, perception and sensory imaging is processed by our brain. So essentially what that means is that when we're looking at our environment, the highly sensitive person has more, like we said, emotional colors to deal with. It takes in more information from our environment. It takes in smaller details that overload our brain and can make us feel, again, really, really overwhelmed. So if you're feeling constantly kind of burnt out by the world, constantly like exhausted by it, you kind of have your genetics to blame because there is a 47% chance that they are what contributed to you being a highly
You actually have a brighter palette of emotional colors, so to speak, because of a variant in a gene that controls how our body's stress response, perception and sensory imaging is processed by our brain. So essentially what that means is that when we're looking at our environment, the highly sensitive person has more, like we said, emotional colors to deal with. It takes in more information from our environment. It takes in smaller details that overload our brain and can make us feel, again, really, really overwhelmed. So if you're feeling constantly kind of burnt out by the world, constantly like exhausted by it, you kind of have your genetics to blame because there is a 47% chance that they are what contributed to you being a highly|||可以这样说，由于控制我们身体的压力反应、感知和感官成像如何被我们大脑处理的基因变异，你实际上拥有一个更明亮的情感色彩调色板。所以本质上这意味着，当我们审视我们的环境时，正如我们所说，高度敏感的人有更多的情感色彩需要处理。它从我们的环境中吸收更多信息。它吸收了更小的细节，这些细节使我们的大脑超载，并再次让我们感到非常非常不知所措。因此，如果你觉得不断地被这个世界烧尽，不断地被它耗尽，你有点得怪你的基因，因为有 47% 的概率它们是你成为一个高度
sensitive person. But a crucial factor that really elevates all those prior determinants and which we really have only scratched the surface on is upbringing. Childhood trauma can create high sensitivity through learning. Learning, what we need to do to survive in those early childhood environments, and also by activating our melancholic temperament or our genetic predisposition. That kind of early environment that is heightened and intense and rough, that may have conditioned you to be very, very alert and responsive to other people's emotions and also what's going on around you, because you had to be.
sensitive person. But a crucial factor that really elevates all those prior determinants and which we really have only scratched the surface on is upbringing. Childhood trauma can create high sensitivity through learning. Learning, what we need to do to survive in those early childhood environments, and also by activating our melancholic temperament or our genetic predisposition. That kind of early environment that is heightened and intense and rough, that may have conditioned you to be very, very alert and responsive to other people's emotions and also what's going on around you, because you had to be.|||敏感的人的原因。但一个真正提升所有这些先前决定因素的关键因素，而我们实际上只是触及了皮毛，那就是抚养方式。童年创伤可以通过学习产生高度敏感。学习，我们需要在那些早期童年环境中做些什么才能生存，以及通过激活我们的忧郁质气质或我们的基因倾向。那种高度紧张、强烈而粗糙的早期环境，可能已经让你变得非常非常警惕，并对别人的情绪以及你周围发生的事情做出反应，因为你不得不这样。
You had to be able to pay attention to navigate that minefield. You had to know what will upset people, what won't. How can I tell if they're angry? What do I need to look out for? How do I stay on their good side by picking up on clues and small things from them that they are unhappy, that they are angry and getting them back to that more, you know, neutral state where I'm not going to be hurt, where I'm not going to get the brunt of things? That hyper alertness and anxiety carries on into adulthood and comes out as hypersensitivity.
You had to be able to pay attention to navigate that minefield. You had to know what will upset people, what won't. How can I tell if they're angry? What do I need to look out for? How do I stay on their good side by picking up on clues and small things from them that they are unhappy, that they are angry and getting them back to that more, you know, neutral state where I'm not going to be hurt, where I'm not going to get the brunt of things? That hyper alertness and anxiety carries on into adulthood and comes out as hypersensitivity.|||你必须能够集中注意力来穿过这个雷区。你必须知道什么会惹人生气，什么不会。我怎么知道他们是否生气？我需要注意什么？如何通过捕捉他们不高兴、生气的线索和小事来保持在他们好的一面，并让他们回到那种更温和的、你知道的、中性的状态，在那里我不会受到伤害，在那里我不会首当其冲地承担一切？这种高度警惕和焦虑一直延续到成年，并表现为高度敏感。
when really it probably was a protective mechanism, a defense mechanism at some stage. It doesn't, you know, those childhood experiences don't even need to constitute the kind of trauma that I think we're imagining. It can even come down to a lack of parental warmth or inconsistency from your caregivers. Warm, supportive, gentle parenting helps children develop healthy emotional regulation. sounds super super simple but if you have a parent who is going to see that you're upset or see that you're angry and sit with you and talk you through it or acknowledge that emotion you basically are able to find a place to put that feeling you're able to find a way to move it from that very instinctual moment where you're reacting and the emotion is very bright and in your face
when really it probably was a protective mechanism, a defense mechanism at some stage. It doesn't, you know, those childhood experiences don't even need to constitute the kind of trauma that I think we're imagining. It can even come down to a lack of parental warmth or inconsistency from your caregivers. Warm, supportive, gentle parenting helps children develop healthy emotional regulation. sounds super super simple but if you have a parent who is going to see that you're upset or see that you're angry and sit with you and talk you through it or acknowledge that emotion you basically are able to find a place to put that feeling you're able to find a way to move it from that very instinctual moment where you're reacting and the emotion is very bright and in your face|||而实际上它在某个阶段可能是一个保护机制、一个防御机制。你知道的，那些童年经历甚至不需要构成我认为我们想象的那种创伤。它甚至可能归结为缺乏父母的温暖或照顾者的不一致。温暖、支持、温柔的育儿方式有助于孩子培养健康的情绪调节能力。听起来超级超级简单，但如果你有一个父母，他看到你心烦意乱或看到你生气，会和你坐在一起，陪你度过难关，或者承认这种情绪，你基本上能够为这种感觉找到一个安放的地方，你能够找到一种方法把它从那个你正在反应的非常本能的时刻转移开，当时情绪非常鲜明并且直面着你
and kind of taper it down find a space for it you know really think it through and make that emotion more neutral. Essentially what I'm kind of saying is that you have healthy coping strategies because someone showed you how to do it. Without those coping strategies, people, children struggle to manage their emotions. And not only does that mean that yes, our emotions feel more out of our control, but it also means that you're very sensitive to stress, to the stress of not being able to manage your emotions, to criticism over not being able to manage your emotions and unexpected social interactions where you don't really know how to behave. You're kind of stressed that like what if I'm suddenly angry or upset or something triggers me?
并逐渐减少它，为它留出空间，你知道的，真正地深思熟虑，让那种情绪变得更加平和。本质上我想说的是，你拥有健康的应对策略，因为有人教过你该怎么做。如果没有这些应对策略，人们——也就是孩子们——就会很难控制自己的情绪。这不仅意味着，是的，我们的情绪感觉更加失控了；这也意味着你对压力非常敏感，对无法控制情绪所带来的压力敏感，对因无法控制情绪而受到的批评敏感，以及对那些你其实不知道该如何应对的意外社交互动敏感。你会有种压力，比如：如果我突然生气、难过，或者有什么东西触动了我的痛点怎么办？
What do I do? Because I just actually don't know how to. So many parents tell their kids to just suck it up or to stop overreacting or to come back when you've calmed down thinking that it's going to make their kids tougher. But if you are already a sensitive child, how are you going to learn? how to process those feelings by yourself when you are just a child. All that is going to do is make your emotions feel even less manageable and you're going to feel even more fearful about talking about it.
我该怎么办？因为我真的不知道怎么做。许多父母告诉他们的孩子“坚强点”、“别反应过度了”或者“等你冷静下来再来找我”，他们以为这样能让孩子变得更坚强。但如果你本身就是一个敏感的孩子，当你还只是个孩子的时候，你怎么可能学会自己去消化那些情绪呢？这么做唯一的作用，就是让你的情绪变得更难以掌控，并让你对谈论这些情绪感到更加恐惧。
You're going to feel so isolated and like you just need to stuff it all down. Otherwise you'll get yelled at. Otherwise you'll get criticized. Otherwise you will be told that you're too sensitive. We also talk a lot about attachment style in this podcast. of course, children who don't receive consistent warmth and affection from their parents will also often develop insecure attachment styles. This can also contribute to hypersensitivity because we become very overly anxious about our
你会感到无比孤立，觉得自己只能把这一切都强压在心底。否则你就会挨骂。否则你就会受到批评。否则别人就会说你太敏感了。在这个播客中，我们也经常讨论依恋类型。当然，那些没有从父母那里获得持续的温暖和关爱的孩子，往往也会形成不安全型依恋。这也可能导致高度敏感，因为我们会对人际关系变得过度焦虑——不仅是恋爱关系，还包括我们平时的各种关系，比如我们和朋友的关系、随意的约会对象、父母以及家人，因为我们对拒绝或批评保持着高度警惕，因为我们害怕被抛弃。我们害怕别人对我们失望或生气。因此，对于任何出现这种迹象的微小信号，我们都会变得草木皆兵。而这正是培养我们高度敏感性的原因。特别是这种对拒绝的敏感，我们在本期节目中其实还没有深入探讨过。
relationships and not just our romantic relationships, but the relationships we have, you know, with our friends when we're casually dating with our parents, with our family, because we are hyper alert to, once again, rejection. or criticism because we fear abandonment. We fear that someone is disappointed or angry with us. And so we become hypervigilant to any small sign that that is the case. And that is what kind of trains our hypersensitivity. And that hypersensitivity to rejection in particular is something that we haven't really spoken about in this episode.
但许多自认为高度敏感的人，对这种感觉有着极其深刻的体会。当他们哪怕感觉到有一点点别人在疏离，或者关系受到威胁时，他们感受到的那种拒绝和敏感是极其强烈的。对于任何人来说这都是可怕的，但如果你高度敏感，这就好比所有事情一下子全都涌了上来。你不仅要考虑别人的情绪、你自己的情绪，还要应对你所在的任何环境。因此，这可能会导致一些我们事后回想起来并不太光彩的行为：比如彻底崩溃爆发、大脑启动最后防线进行彻底关闭——“我们干脆关机吧，这样就不用处理了”——甚至把对方推得更远，因为至少这样能把压力的根源赶走。
But a lot of people who identify as highly sensitive feel that very intense. intensely. They feel that rejection and sensitivity incredibly intensely when they get even the slightest feeling that someone is pulling away or that a relationship is under threat. That is scary for anyone, but if you're highly sensitive, it's so much all at once. It's so much having to think about someone else's emotions, your emotions, whatever environment you're in. And so it can lead to behaviors that we don't feel so proud of later on lashing out completely shutting down as like our brain's final defense like line of defense like let's just shut this down so we don't have to deal with this pushing someone away even more because at least that's going to take the source of our stress
如果你感到如此如履薄冰、如此不堪重负，有时候你唯一想做的事情就是逃避，选择不去面对。因此，你会选择推开、逃跑，或者只是找个方法去逃避。当我们终于有了空间和独处时间来真正梳理我们的视角和反应时（你知道的，很多高度敏感的人确实需要这样的时间），有时我们会觉得木已成舟，甚至无法再回去道歉或再次面对他们，因为这实在太沉重了。这简直太让人吃不消了。正因如此，我们也会看到一种冲突回避的循环。当然，如果你高度敏感，冲突对你来说会极其艰难，因为所有感觉都被放大、加剧、拔高了。你能感知到别人察觉不到的微小变化。
away then if you are feeling so on edge so overwhelmed sometimes all you want to do is just escape and just not deal with it. And so you push or you run away or you just find a way to avoid. When we finally had the space and the alone time to really work through our perspective and our reaction, you know, a lot of highly sensitive people do need that time. Sometimes we do feel like the damage is done or that we can't even go back and apologize or confront them again because it's just too much. It's just way too much. And in that way, we also see a cycle of. conflict aversion. Of course, conflict is going to be so hard for you if you're highly sensitive because everything is elevated, magnified, heightened. You're sensing subtle shifts that they don't.
你能感知到他们的情绪。你试图控制自己的反应。这会让你感到极其不知所措。由于这种感官过载，有时你可能会说错话。你只是希望这一切赶快结束。你不可能总是消化所有同时涌现的事情。即使我们已经尽了最大努力，这也依然很难，特别是当我们沟通的对象根本无法理解时。我们并不是在故意找茬。我们并没有过度解读你的话。我们不是故意要感到沮丧。我们正在拼命忍住不哭，因为我们不想让你把我们轻描淡写地归咎为“过于敏感”。
You're perceiving their emotions. You're trying to manage your own reactions. It can feel very overwhelming. Because of that sensory overload, sometimes you can say the wrong things. You just want it to end. You can't always process everything that's coming together at once. It's hard even when we actually do try our hardest, especially when people, the people that we're communicating with just don't get it. Like, we're not trying to be difficult. We're not reading too much into what you're saying. We're not trying to get frustrated. We're trying really hard not to cry because we don't want you to dismiss us as just being overly sensitive.
但我们的脑海里有太多的杂音在嗡嗡作响。我们对这种感觉体会得太深了。这种情绪太强烈了。你还能怎么办呢？如果你发现自己陷入了这种模式中，而你的伴侣、父母或朋友却根本不理解，认为你可能是在用眼泪作为一种内疚的手段，或者认为你无法保持冷静是因为你选择不这么做——请把这一期节目发给他们，因为我认为，一旦人们有了更多关于你的大脑是如何以不同于他们的方式运作的信息，就会产生更多的同理心、理解和调整。他们也有望能够去倾听、去理解这样一个事实：这不是一种选择。有一个非常精彩的TED演讲叫做《高度敏感之人的温柔力量》（The Gentle Power of Highly Sensitive People）。强烈推荐这个演讲。在演讲中，演讲者谈到，告诉一个敏感的人“收敛一点”、“别让世界伤害你”、“变得不那么敏感一点”，就像告诉一个蓝眼睛的人让他们的眼睛不那么蓝一样。无论你对他们说多少次，你看到的很可能依然是那双蓝眼睛在注视着你。
But there is so much buzzing around in our brains. We feel this so deeply. The emotion is so intense. What else are you meant to do? if you find yourself in that pattern with a partner, with a parent, with a friend, who just doesn't understand, who thinks that maybe you're using tears as like a guilt mechanism or that you just can't stay calm and it's because you're choosing not to, please send them this episode because I think once people have more information
敏感也是如此。这不是你随手一按就能关闭的东西。说实话，我甚至不认为这是你应该去关闭的东西。我在这里稍微倒退一下，因为关于这个话题，还有一个我们需要讨论的因素和解释。如果对神经多样性闭口不谈，那就太短视了。人们经常被告知他们只是太敏感了，而实际上这可能是他们在掩盖自己的自闭症或ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍），因为这两种情况的行为模式真的非常相似，而且它们常常同时出现，所以你可能同时具备这两种特质。
about how your brain is working and operating differently to them, there is more empathy and understanding and adjustment. They also can kind of hopefully lean in and understand the fact that this isn't a choice. There is this amazing TED talk called The Gentle Power of Highly Sensitive People. Highly recommend that talk. And in it, the speaker talks about how telling a sensitive person to just tone it down, to not let the world hurt them, to be less sensitive, is like telling a person with blue eyes to make their eyes less blue. no matter how many times you tell them, chances are you're still going to see those blue eyes staring back at you.
但真正令人沮丧的是，当人们被简单地视为“太敏感”或“太情绪化”，或者被告知需要坚强一点时，他们的敏感其实正是某种更大、更深层问题的一个信号。患有ADHD的人通常发现，他们需要更少的刺激就会感到不知所措。因此，在这种情况下，他们就会表现出高度敏感。自闭症患者也是如此，对吧？比如，有时新的环境、新的情况，甚至新的感觉都会让他们觉得难以承受。或者在那些很难判断别人在想什么、你无法捕捉到这些线索的情境下，这会让人觉得你非常敏感或反应过度。
And the same goes for sensitivity. It's not something that you can just switch off. And to be honest, I don't even think that it's something that you should switch off. I'm going to go backwards here for a second because there's one more element explanation for this that we need to discuss. It would be so short-sighted to not mention neurodivergence. So often someone is told that they are just. just too sensitive when it's actually them masking their autism or their ADHD because the pattern of behaviours are really, really similar and they're often comorbid so you can have both at once.
事实上，你只是不太清楚到底发生了什么。这完全没关系。有时候，人类的情感并非一本翻开就能看懂或合上的书。无论你是有可以诊断并共存的障碍，还是你只是一个高度敏感的人，我认为这其实都一样。管理你的情绪反应依然会很艰难，而且你仍然会觉得人们对高度敏感抱有一种偏见。人们会认为你软弱、脆弱，诸如此类。现在我要对大家格外坦诚。
But what's really frustrating is when people are just seen as too sensitive or too emotional or told that they need to toughen up when their sensitivity is actually a sign of something bigger and larger. People with ADHD often find it takes less stimulation for them to be overwhelmed. So in that way, they are going to present as highly sensitive. The same goes for people with autism, right? Like, sometimes new environments, new situations, even new feelings can just feel like a lot. Or in situations where it's just really hard to tell what people are thinking you're not picking up on those cues, it's going to make it seem like you're being really sensitive or reactive.
我对这一观点的态度是坚决反对羞耻感。坚决反对“让我们为所有高度敏感的人寻找解药，让我们变得正常”这种想法。我不想让我们压抑自己的情绪，我不想让我们试图伪装成变色龙，去努力融入那80%所谓的具有平均敏感水平的人群中。因为首先，这会适得其反，我们会感到更加不知所措；所以这不仅不管用，还会让我们感觉更糟。其次，我实在找不到任何理由让你非要这么做。我真的认为敏感其实是一种超能力。温柔、情绪化、敏锐并能与他人同频共振，这是一种相当美妙、相当特别的特质。你知道的，这种特质是不会改变的，它伴随一生。
Actually, you just don't really know what's going on. And that's totally okay. Sometimes, like, human emotion is not like an open and closed book. whether you have a diagnosable disorder that's comorbid or you are just someone who is highly sensitive. I think it's all the same. It's still going to be difficult to manage your emotional reactions and you're still going to feel like people have some kind of stigma around high sensitivity. People think that you're weak or that you're fragile or whatever. I'm going to be super honest with you all now.
希望听到这个消息不会让你觉得太难接受，但我认为，我们越早接受这一点，生活就会感觉越轻松，就越有解放感——那种需要调低自己光芒的沉重感被卸下了。因为一旦我们承认“这是我的一部分，它不会消失，也不会改变”，你就会在那个时刻意识到，为了维持余生的虚假面具会有多么令人筋疲力尽。最终你会意识到，也许你根本不应该这么做，也许这根本不值得，也许生活并不全是为了让别人和你在一起时感到舒适，而是为了让你的生活让你自己感到舒适。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我想要探讨所有这些以及更多内容——如何真正让世界适应你的敏感，而不是反过来让你的敏感去适应世界。
My perspective on this is very anti-shame. very anti-let's find a cure for all us highly sensitive people let's make us normal i don't want us to suppress our emotions i don't want us to try and chameleon or try and blend in with the 80% of people who quote-unquote have average sensitivity levels because firstly it backfires we feel even more overwhelmed so not only does it not work it makes us feel worse and secondly i just don't see a reason why you should i really think that sensitivity is kind of a superpower being gentle and emotional and attune and in tune with others is quite gorgeous and quite special to have you know this trait isn't going to change it's a lifelong thing
购买贝尔纯光纤互联网，搭配Crave、Netflix和Disney Plus，每月只需94加元起。两年期互联网合同享两年价格保证，并可享受自动付款优惠。访问bell.com了解详情并查询可用性。贝尔，连接一切。我是尼克·图图罗（Nick Tuturo）。你可能在《纽约重案组》（NYPD Blue）、《最长的一码》（The Longest Yard）或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》（Black Klansman）中认识我。但我也是土生土长的皇后区人，这意味着我很懂披萨。
hopefully that's not too hard to hear but i think the earlier we come to terms with that the easier life feels the more freeing it's like the weight of needing to dim down is lifted because once we acknowledge like this is part of who I am it's not going away it's not going to change it's kind of at that point that you realize how exhausting is going to be to keep you know to keep up the facade for the rest of your life and eventually you realize that maybe you just shouldn't maybe it's not worth it maybe life isn't all about trying to make other people feel comfortable with you and it's about trying to make your life feel comfortable for yourself so I want to talk about all of that and more how to really make the world fit your sensitivity rather than the
在我的新播客《用尼克·图图罗传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Toturo）中，我把普林斯街披萨店（Prince Street Pizza）的披萨送到一位新嘉宾面前。你现在开始送披萨了吗？然后我们坐下来进行一次真正的对话。我和各种各样的人分享过一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）——你在对我的腰带做什么？到亚历山大·罗德里格斯（Alex Rodriguez）。
other way around after this short break. Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Crave Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.com for details and to check availability. Bell. Connection is everything. I'm Nick Tutoril. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard. or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza.
顺便告诉各位，我们今天采访的是史上最伟大的人物之一。再到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我觉得我从来没见过哪个人的精神状态像我一样这么出格。现在，我们还将迎来更多重量级嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·图图罗（John Tuturo）。这个节目叫《快乐》。
And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez.
《传递快乐》。马里亚诺·里维拉（Mariano Rivera）。哦，天哪。还有许许多多其他人。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Delivering Happiness with Nick Toturo》。现在就收听。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》（Dear Chelsea）的切尔西·汉德勒（Chelsea Handler）。
Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, We even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness.
每周，新闻都在变得更糟。世界变得越来越疯狂。而亚玛尼卡（Yamanika）来到这里，是要向所有肇事者宣告：你才是问题所在。如果你来这里想玩游戏，我会管教你的。好吗？如果你在新闻里做了什么听起来不太好的事，我绝不轻饶。加入亚玛尼卡·桑德斯（Yamanika Saunders）的新播客，听她剖析本周最具争议的故事。这就是亚玛尼卡带给你的《你才是问题所在》（You're the Problem with Yamanika）。
Delivering happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro. And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea.
你知道我刚刚发现西德妮·西恩妮（Sydney Sweeney）是谁吗？每周三更新节目，这是我的新网络“亲爱的切尔西网络”（The Dear Chelsea Network）的一部分。如果他能拥有一群女人，那我也应该拥有一群男人。要么表现得更好，要么少干涉，免得我不得不付出那么多。所以请每期都加入亚玛尼卡的节目，看她如何回答一个问题。谁才是问题所在？我是亚玛尼卡，我先走一步。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听亚玛尼卡的《你才是问题所在》。
Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'm a check you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm gonna play you. Join Yamanika Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast. You're the problem with Yamanika.
最近怎么样，老铁们？我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯（Ari Chambers）。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？我是你们的女孩萨姆·J（Sam J）。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》（Everyone Watches Women's Sports）的主持人，这是来自Together and I Heart Women's Sports的全新播客。因为说实话。如今女子体育给我们提供了太多可以谈论的话题。比如凯尔西·芬勒（Kelsey Finler），她成为了第三个。第一位独自从加利福尼亚划船到夏威夷的女性划船手。我的第一反应是：零食怎么办？呃，我们在吃什么？
Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the Dear Chelsea Network. If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. So join Yomeneke each episode as she and, answers one question. Who's the problem? I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
精彩集锦、宿敌对决、新星崛起、那些刷屏整个时间轴的时刻。以及在比赛期间开始、并且不知为何能持续讨论一整周的话题。每周，我们都在剖析女子体育领域的各大重磅故事。大坂直美（Naomi Osaka）大放异彩，她击败了萨巴伦卡（Sabalinka）。向你致敬，大坂直美。你赢得了掌声，大坂直美。你实至名归。因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣。我们更对为什么所有人都在谈论它感兴趣。
What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and I Heart Women's Sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the third. first female solo rower to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating?
因为每个人都在看女子体育。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。嘿，Portlandia的粉丝们。我是嘉莉·布朗斯坦（Carrie Brownstein）和弗莱德·阿米森（Fred Armisen）。你们认识我们，或者更准确地说，你们认识他们。托尼（Tony）和坎迪斯（Candice），妮娜（Nina）和兰斯（Lance）。
The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments that take over your entire timeline. And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out, she beat Sabalinka. Shoutouts to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi. You get the palm for that. Because we're not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it
斯派克（Spike），还有，没错，那只鸡。这些年来我们塑造了许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以真实的自我出现，来向大家介绍我们的全新播客《Podlandia，AEO重温之旅》（Podlandia, AEO Rewatch）。每周我们将从头开始重温一集《Portlandia》，剖析剧中的小品。
because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us, or rather, you know them. Tony and Candice, Nina and Lance,
探索我们最具标志性的角色的背景故事，重访你们熟悉并喜爱的波特兰拍摄地，并敞开心扉讲述我们的创作过程。这一切究竟是怎么拍出来的？为什么我们当时会觉得那是个好主意？我们准备好聊聊这些了。而且，帮助我们将这一切变为现实的幕后功臣也将加入我们。
Spike, and yes, the chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO, rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches,
客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友们，包括导演乔纳森·克里萨尔（Jonathan Chrysall）、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦（Kyle McLaughlin）、传奇音乐家艾米·曼（Amy Mann）等等。凯尔在这里可以说是全力以赴。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌、一段旋律。我以为他要写歌。我以为你们所有人都要写歌。
exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life.
我记得你是这么想的。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Podlandia：AEO重温之旅》。高度敏感的人是我最喜欢与之相处的人群之一，因为他们能让身边的人看到一个更美丽的世界。他们同时也极其温柔、富有同理心。他们充满创造力，并且在他们所做的每一件事中都倾注了巨大的热忱与爱意。对他们而言，没有什么是无足轻重的。你身边那个高度敏感的朋友，大概就是那个会记住你生日的人。
Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody. I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song.
他们大概会是那个让你感到最有安全感的人。是那个会向你介绍新音乐的人。是那个想和你一起去进行漫长自然徒步的人。是那个会指出你没有注意到的微小细节的人。他们是那种能让你在他们的空间里感到舒适的人。会在恋爱关系中给予你无尽的爱。我只是不明白为什么我们不希望世界上多一些这样的人。把一切都感受得如此深刻有时可能感觉像是一种诅咒，但与对一切都毫无感觉、从未被那种快乐触动过。
I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo, rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Highly sensitive people are some of my favorites to be around because they make the people around them see the world more beautifully. They are also incredibly gentle and empathetic. they are creative and they just bring big heart and big love to everything that they do. Like nothing is small for them. Your highly sensitive friend is probably going to be the one who remembers your birthday.
从未深刻感受到自己作为人类的活力相比，有时我真的觉得这是一种特权。比如，我遇到过一些对什么都不在乎的人。他们没有任何正义感。他们对美、对惊叹或对兴奋没有任何感知，那是一种相当乏味的人生。除此之外，研究和科学也会告诉你，你的智商、情商、创造力智商、情感生动度、感官智商可能都高于常人。我认为这让我们能够真正专注于成为一个高度敏感的人所带来的力量，即使在我们被告知“你想得太多/你太过了”的时候也是如此。
They are probably going to be the one who makes you feel safest. Who is going to introduce you to new music. Who wants to go on long nature walks with you. Who will, you know, point out small things that you didn't notice. They are the ones who are going to make you feel comfortable. comfortable in their space. It was going to give you so much love in a relationship. I just don't understand why we don't want more of that in the world. Feeling everything so deeply might sometimes feel like a curse, but compared to feeling nothing at all and never being touched by that joy
说那些话的人，说实话，他们可以克服。他们完全可以克服。你的人生目标不是为了让别人和你在一起时感到舒服。如果有人觉得你太激烈、感受太强烈，如果他们觉得你反应过度，他们的意见只是反映了他们准备向他人展示的同情心水平。而不是反映了你以及你的人生中需要改变的地方。我只是不理解——是谁定下了“太敏感是一件坏事”这样的规矩？我在为这一期节目做研究时，听到一个非常了不起的人说：
and never feeling deeply human, sometimes I do think it's a privilege. Like, I have met people who just don't care about anything. They don't have any sense of justice. They don't have any any sense of beauty or wonder or or excitement and it's a pretty bland life. That on top of the fact that, you know, the research and the science will tell you, your IQ, your EQ, your creative intelligence, your emotional vividness, your sensory intelligence is probably higher than the average person. I think that keeps us really focused on the strength that comes with being a highly sensitive person, even during the times when we're told that we're too much.
当有人对我说我太敏感时，我总是反驳他们说：“嗯，也许是你太麻木不仁了。”仅仅因为我看待世界的方式更为罕见，并不意味着它更糟糕，也不意味着它是需要被修复的那一个。好了，废话少说，让我们来聊聊一些建议，谈谈如何让一个麻木不仁的世界更适合你那美丽敏感的灵魂。首先，如果你想对作为一个高度敏感的人感到更加自在，你真的需要通过了解你生活中的什么事情能让你更轻松、更无负担，以及什么事情会让事情变得更艰难，来尊重你的敏感。高度敏感的人就是需要比其他人更多的时间来处理他们的一天、他们的环境以及他们的人际关系中发生的事情。所以，给自己这段时间，而不是试图强行超载自己去迎合他人。注意自己的极限，把自己置于不会让事情变得更艰难的环境中。因此，举个例子，如果你明天早上要和老板进行一次重要的通话，就不要在同一天安排与老朋友进行高强度的叙旧。把事情错开。
Those people who say that, I'm going to be completely honest, they can get over it. They can get over it. Your purpose in life is not to make others comfortable with you. If someone thinks that you are too intense, feels too strongly, if they think that you overreact, their opinion is a reflection of the level of empathy that they are prepared to show others. Not a reflection of you and what needs to change in your life. I just don't, like, who made the rules that said that being too sensitive is a bad thing? I heard from this really amazing person when I was researching this episode who said,
给自己时间恢复到正常、平稳、稳定的状态，然后再投入到下一个情境中。我认为，适应作为一个高度敏感的人，或者仅仅是适应你对作为高度敏感者的身份的承认与尊重，意味着去欣赏并最终接受：也许你无法像其他人那样做所有事情。但这并不意味着你做不到。
when someone tells me I'm being too sensitive, I always come back to them and say, well, maybe you're being too insensitive. Just because my way of seeing the world is more rare doesn't make it worse and it doesn't make it the one that needs fixing. So that rant aside, let's talk about some tips about how to make an insensitive world more suitable for your beautiful sensitive soul. First off the bat, if you want to get more comfortable with being a highly sensitive person, you really need to honour your sensitivity by learning what in your life makes things easier for you
这只是意味着你必须找到一种适合自己的方式来完成它。否则，过程将会极其痛苦。我的第二个建议是，去实践那种对你管用的自我关怀，因为它可能看起来与世界上80%的人喜欢做的自我关怀截然不同。你知道的，对某些人来说，自我关怀就是社交。是犒劳自己、去购物、释放压力。而对你来说，它可能需要你慢下来、休息并说“不”。你知道的：“不，抱歉，我不想去那家拥挤的餐厅吃晚饭。”“不，我不想让你的朋友加入我们的晚餐。”
and lighter for you and what makes things feel harder. Highly sensitive people just need more time than others to process the things that happen in their day, in their environment, in their relationships. So give yourself that time rather than trying to overload yourself to fit in. Notice your limits and put yourself in environments that aren't going to make things more difficult for you. So for example, if you've got a big call with your boss tomorrow morning, don't schedule an intense catch up with an old friend in the same day. Space things out.
“抱歉，我现在不想谈这个。”自我关怀既在于为生活增添事物，也在于对生活中的事物说“不”并做减法。为自己留出充足的停机时间来进行情绪调节。给自己时间去休息和思考。你知道还有什么是一种深刻而甜蜜、简单却常被忽视的自我关怀形式吗？就是给自己更多的时间去赶往某个地方，给自己更多的时间来安排一整天。比方说，提前五分钟结束工作。即使你内心渴望继续工作，你也知道你需要这五分钟来把你的现实生活和工作生活分离开来，并真正回到稳定、平稳的状态。给自己多留出10到15分钟去某个地方，即使这意味着你会早到，因为你不想变得慌乱、燥热、黏糊糊、精疲力竭，你不想在本来准备出门的时候却讨厌自己身上衣服的质感，然后还得急急忙忙换衣服。给自己多留出一点时间。我认为在自我关怀方面至关重要的规则——黄金法则，就是根据过去伤害过你或让你感到不知所措的经历，为未来的自己做出明智的选择，这些选择将帮助未来的你。我曾听一个朋友讲过一个她使用的技巧，有点类似于这个想法。她是这么做的：她
Give yourself time to return to that normal, steady, stable state, before you throw yourself into the next situation. I think adjusting to being a highly sensitive person or just adjusting to your acknowledgement and your respect of your identity as a highly sensitive person means appreciating and finally accepting that maybe you can't do everything the way that everyone else does it. It doesn't mean that you can't do it though.
在自己的家里甚至工作场所都创造了放松区。去过她家之后，那感觉就像走进了你所见过的最舒适、最温馨的治疗师办公室。她甚至都不是治疗师。那里就是那么令人平静。空气中总是弥漫着柠檬和蜂蜜的香味。从来没有任何刺眼的大顶灯亮着。你目光所及之处都有舒适的表面。
It just means that you have to find a way for it to work with you. Otherwise it's just going to be really unenjoyable. My second piece of advice is to practice the kind of self-care that works for you because it's probably going to look different from the self-care that 80% of the world likes to do. You know, for some people, self-care is socializing. It's treating themselves, going shopping, letting loose. For you, it's probably going to involve slowing down, resting and saying no. You know, no, sorry, I don't want to go to dinner at that crowd of restaurant. No, I don't want your friend, I don't like to join us for dinner.
那里有各种美好的事物。走进那样的环境，你就会非常明显地感受到，她是刻意为自己打造了一个安全空间，并且她为此付出了超越常规的努力。她以前曾付出过努力，为未来的每一个版本的自己提供这份礼物——那些在经历了漫长而疲惫的一天、吸收了周围所有人的情绪和周围的一切之后，只想平静下来、却需要走进家门的自己——她把这一切作为礼物送给了自己。我之所以真的很喜欢她这样做，是因为当你走进她的房子时，你会觉得你的身体、
Sorry, I don't want to have this conversation right now. Self-care is as much about adding things to your life as it is about saying no and subtracting things in your life. To give yourself adequate downtime to emotionally regulate. To give yourself time to rest and to think. You know what else is like a profoundly sweet, simple but overlooked form of self-care? just giving yourself more time to get places, giving yourself more time to organize your day. Finish up your work, you know, just five minutes earlier. Even if you feel drawn to keep working, you know that you'll need that five minutes to separate
你的心灵、你的灵魂，无论是什么，都被净化了。作为一个高度敏感的人，这就好像穿着一双非常非常粘的鞋子走在外面。你会粘上很多东西。你会粘上口香糖。你会粘上烟头。你会粘上鸽子粪。然后你把这一切都带回了家。
your real life from your work life and to really get back into a stable, steady state. Give yourself the extra 10, 15 minutes to get somewhere, even if it means getting there early because you don't want to be flustered, you don't want to be hot, sticky, overwhelmed, you don't want to hate the texture of your outfit, you know, right when you're meant to be leaving and then feel rushed to change. Give yourself a bit more time. I think the crucial rule when it comes to self-care, the golden rule, is make smart choices that will help your future self based on what has hurt or overwhelmed your past self. I had a friend tell me about a technique she uses that it's kind of similar to that idea. And it's called, what she does is she
而且，你知道的，你吸收了情绪。你吸收了感官过载。你吸收了某人在火车上进行的那场令人精疲力竭的对话、刺眼的灯光以及诸如此类的所有东西。你把这一切都带回家了。当你到家时，你需要清理滤网。你需要把鞋子上的脏东西清理干净。因为你和大家不一样。你是一个信息的收集者。这就是你的
creates relaxing zones in her house and even at her job. And having been to her home, it is like walking into the most comfortable and homely therapist office that you've ever been in. She's not even a therapist. It's just so calming. It always smells like lemon and honey. There are never any like really big overhead lights on. She has cozy surfaces everywhere you look.
大脑根据你的基因、根据你的童年、根据所有促成你高度敏感的因素而进化出的功能。所有这一切都只是让外界对你而言变得更加喧嚣。所以你需要一个空间，能让你把音量调小，并把脑海里的垃圾清理干净、冲洗掉。作为一个高度敏感的人，我还认为，谨慎选择你所陪伴的人是很有必要的。你就像一块海绵。你永远与周围的人处于渗透状态中。你吸收他们的情绪、他们的反应、他们的恐惧、他们的喜悦。如果你身边的人、你的朋友反应过度、或者极度不可预测、戏剧化、情绪总是处于极高极高或极低极低的状态，你猜你会有什么感觉？完全一模一样。
She has beautiful things. And walking into that environment, it's just like so obvious that she has intentionally made this a safe space for herself and that she has gone out of her way. She's put in the effort before to, you know, provide this gift to every future version of her who needs to walk into her home after a big, long day where she's been absorbing everyone else's emotions and everything around her and she just wants to calm down and she has given that to herself. And the reason why I really like that she's done this is because when you walk into her house, you just feel like your body.
我看到很多人拼命地想要和那些
your mind, your soul, whatever it is, is being cleansed. And as a highly sensitive person, it's kind of like walking outside in really, really sticky shoes. And like you pick up so many things. You pick up the gum. You pick up the cigarette butts. You pick up the pigeon poop. And you take it all home with you.
根本不应该成为朋友的人做朋友。并不是因为这些人有什么毒性、糟糕透顶或其他什么标签。只是他们不该做朋友，因为他们的情感能量不在同一个频线上。结果往往会变糟，因为他们感受到的所有情绪，你全盘接收。因此，你很难做到不把事情放在心上，或者每次聚会后都感觉精疲力竭。感觉你再也不想见到他们了。或者感觉如坐针毡、情绪爆发、说出一些你并非出自本意的话。
And, you know, you pick up the emotions. You pick up the sensory overload. You pick up the exhausting conversation someone was having on the train and the loud lights and whatever it is. And you take that all home with you. And when you get home, you need to clean out the filter. You need to clean off the sherry. shoes because you are not like everyone else. You are a collector of information. That's what your
当然，这条建议并不是说让你甩掉所有的朋友、一切从头开始，而是去真正评估一下：我和谁互动后会感到平静、安宁和被看见？我和谁互动后会感到如坐针毡、精疲力竭、神经紧绷？也许那些人应该变成“偶尔见一次”的朋友，而不是每天都在一起的朋友。顺便说一句，我想划定最后一条底线。任何再次说你太情绪化、说你把事情看得太重、说你需要冷静下来的人，都永远不应该成为你的朋友。
brain has developed to do based on your genetics, based on your childhood, based on whatever has contributed to your high sensitivity. All of that has just made everything much louder for you. So you need a space that allows you to turn it down and to kind of clean off the junk and clean out the junk from your brain. As a highly sensitive person, I also think it's worth being selective about the people you choose to be around. You are like a sponge. You are perpetually in a state of osmosis with the people around you. You absorb their emotions, their reactions, their fears, their joy. If the people around you, your friends are super reactive or really unpredictable, dramatic, always really high, high, high or extremely low, guess how you're going to be feeling? The exact same way.
他们不配拥有你。这只能怪他们自己，因为他们无法被你的温柔、你对美、同理心和善良的极致欣赏所触及。他们享受不到你身上这一特质所带来的礼物。但我真的认为这是他们的损失，因为如果他们不愿意接受你的每一个部分——包括我老实说认为既独特又美丽的那个部分——那他们就不合格。他们不配出现在你的生活中。你知道的，你最终会察觉到他们对你的看法，这只会让你一直处于高度紧张的状态。如果有人说：“你知道的，你就是太敏感了。”这时候回怼他们也是很值得的，比如：“你知道吗，这挺棒的，我可喜欢了。我喜欢自己能够拥有如此丰富的感受。”别再试图……你知道的，他们没资格让你感到糟糕。如果他们说你反应过度，直接对他们说：“嗯，那什么样的反应才算恰当呢？”或者“我只是觉得你看待问题的方式和我不一样。我觉得你反应不足。”你可以坚持自我。仅仅因为你的敏感被贴上了软弱的标签，它首先并不是软弱。但你有权持不同意见。你有权说：“不，事实上我真的很喜欢我身上的这一部分。”
I see so many people try really hard to be friends. with people they are just, you know, just simply shouldn't be friends with. Not because those people are toxic or awful or any of those labels. They just shouldn't be friends because their emotional energies don't align. And it ends up going sour because everything they feel, you feel. And so it becomes hard not to take things personally or to leave every hangout feeling super drained. And like you just don't want to see them again. Or feeling really on edge and snapping or saying something you don't mean.
我真的很喜欢这个特质带给我的那个我。我喜欢我能注意到细节。我喜欢我热爱这个世界。所以我要保持这样。谢谢你的意见。下一个。我真的希望这一期节目能在某种程度上对你有所帮助。我希望它将你正在经历的情绪体验或某种视角进行了正常化。我希望你觉得自己被看见了。我希望你觉得自己被听见了。我希望你觉得自己被拥抱了、被爱着，因为我是真的很喜欢高度敏感的人。他们是我最爱的人。你们是我最爱的人。我只是觉得他们让这个世界变得如此特别。如果没有他们，这个世界将会变得多么残酷、多么丑陋。
Now, this piece of advice isn't to say drop all your friends, start from scratch, but really assess who do I leave interactions with, feeling calm, serene and seen? Who do I leave interactions with, feeling on edge, exhausted, highly strong? Maybe those people become a once-in-a-while friend, rather than an everyday friend. On that note, I want to say one final boundary. anyone again who says you are too emotional, who says that you take things too personally, that you need to calm down, those people should be never friends.
所以，谢谢你们用存在的方式为我们大家服务。像往常一样，如果你喜欢这一期节目，请把它发给你的朋友。我相信他们会很乐意听听看的。把它发给那些可能不太懂你那敏感大脑的人，这样他们就能多了解一点。我相信他们会很感激能与你在同一频道上。请确保在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何平台上留下五星好评，
They don't deserve you. And it's too bad for them because they don't get to be touched by your gentleness and your extreme appreciation for beauty and empathy and kindness. They don't get the gift of this aspect of you. but I honestly think that it is their loss because if they're not willing to accept every single part of you including the part of you that honestly I think is so unique and beautiful they're just not it they don't deserve to be in your life and you know that you will end up picking up on how
并持续关注，以便收听即将推出的更多精彩节目。另外，如果你有什么节目建议，或者如果你是一个高度敏感的人，想要跟我多聊聊你的经历——也许是为了做一期后续节目，或者是为了我在Instagram上发布的内容——请在Instagram上私信我：
they're feeling about you and it's just going to always keep you in a heightened state if someone says you know you're just so sensitive it's also worthwhile just saying back to them like you know I know it's great I love it I love that I get to feel so much much. Stop trying, like, you know, they're not allowed to make you feel bad. If they say you're overreacting, literally just be like, um, so what would an appropriate reaction be? Or I just don't think that you're seeing the situation in the same way. I think you're underreacting. You're, you're allowed to assert yourself just because your sensitivity has been labeled as weakness. It's not, firstly. But you're allowed to disagree. You're allowed to say, actually, no, I really like this part
@That Psychology podcast。我很期待听到你们的声音。在此之前，请保持安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。对你那敏感的小灵魂温柔一点。这是你应得的，我们很快就会再聊。嘿，Portlandia的粉丝们。
of me. I actually really like who it makes me. I like that I notice things. I like that I love the world. So I'm going to keep it that way. Thank you for your opinion. Moving on. I really do hope that this episode has helped you in some way. I hope that it's normalized an emotional experience that you're having or a perspective. I hope that you feel seen. I hope that you feel heard. I hope that you feel held and that you feel loved because I really do love highly sensitive people. They're my favorites. You are my favorite. I just think that they make the world so special. Without them, the world would be so cruel and so ugly.
我是嘉莉·布朗斯坦和弗莱德·阿米森。“90年代的梦想”在播客的形式中复活了。我们推出了全新播客《Podlandia，AEO重温之旅》（Podlandia, AEO Rewatch）。在这里，我们将一起重温每一集的《Portlandia》，剖析剧中的小品，深入探讨我们标志性的角色，并揭开这一切是如何被制作出来的幕后故事。而且，帮助我们将这一切变为现实的幕后功臣也将加入我们。
So thank you for doing us all the service by existing. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, send it to a friend. I'm sure that they would love to hear it. Send it to someone who maybe just doesn't get your sensitive brain so that they can learn a little bit more. I'm sure they would appreciate being able to be on your level. Make sure that you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now
客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友们，包括导演乔纳森·克里萨尔、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦、传奇音乐家艾米·曼等等。凯尔在这里可以说是全力以赴。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌。好吧，我以为你们所有人都要写歌。我记得你是这么想的。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Podlandia：AEO重温之旅》。我的第一位嘉宾是特蕾丝·希尔顿（Teres Hilton）、夏奇拉（Shakira）、卢克（Luke）和耶林（Yerrin）。这里有惊喜。
and that you are following along for more episodes coming out soon. Also, if you have an episode suggestion, if you're a highly sensitive person and you want to tell me a little bit more about your experience, maybe for a follow-up episode, for something that I might post on Instagram, please DM me on Instagram
许许多多的惊喜。莫娜（Mona）。欢迎收听《Sweet 305》播客，在这里，群体聊天变成了现实。天哪！你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。那是柠檬味的。这里是《Sweet 305》。在这里，过度分享是受到鼓励的。
at That Psychology podcast. I would love to hear from you, and until next time, stay safe, stay kind. Be gentle to yourself. Be gentle to your sensitive little soul. You deserve it, and we will talk. soon. Hey, Portlandia fans.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听由莱le·庞斯（Lele Pons）主持的《Sweet 305》。最近怎么样，老铁们？我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？我是你们的女孩萨姆·J。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人，这是来自Together and I Heart Women's Sports的全新播客。我们正在剖析最大的头条新闻。大坂直美，大放异彩。
Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more.
向你致敬，大坂直美。那些病毒式的爆火时刻。我一直沉迷于卡山·罗克（Kashan Rock）的拳击历程。她看起来状态很好。她的组合拳很迅猛。以及所有人都在女子体育领域热议的故事。因为每个人都在看女子体育。在iHeart Radio应用程序上收听《每个人都在看女子体育》，
Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My first guest is Teres Hilton, Shakira, Luke, and Yerrin. Have surprises.
Apple Podcasts，或在任何你获取播客的地方收听。我是尼克·图图罗。你可能在《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》中认识我。在我的新播客《用尼克·图图罗传递快乐》中，我把披萨送给一位新嘉宾。我和从赛斯·罗林斯——你在对我的腰带做什么？到比尔·伯尔的每个人都分享过一块披萨。
Many surprises. Mona. Welcome to the Sweet 305 podcast where the group check comes to life. What on! You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. This is Sweet 305. Here, oversharing is encouraged.
我觉得我从来没见过哪个人的精神状态像我一样这么出格。现在，我们还将迎来更多重量级嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·图图罗。这个节目叫《快乐》。
Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of Everyone Watches Women's Sports, a new podcast from Together in I Heart Women's Sports. We're breaking down the biggest headlines. Naomi Osaka, showing out.
《传递快乐》。还有许许多多其他人。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Delivering Happiness with Nick Toturo》。现在就收听。我是杰克·布伦南（Jake Brennan）。在《耻辱之地》（Disgrace Land）播客中，我将揭露
Shout-hows to you, Naomi. The viral moments. I've been obsessed with Kashan Rock's boxing journey. She looks good. Her combos are swift. And the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app,
摇滚巨星们的疯狂谎言以及音乐史上令人难以置信的真实犯罪故事。这些都是你未曾听闻的故事，那种你会忍不住讲给别人听的故事。比如保罗·麦卡特尼（Paul McCartney）在臭名昭著的监狱里度过的时光，或者Lady Gaga被指控的离奇罪行，再或者是金发美女乐队（Blondie）的黛比·哈里（Debbie Harry）逃脱泰迪·邦迪（Ted Bundy）魔爪的那次经历。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Disgrace Land》。
Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Tuturo. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the Longest Yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Tutorial, I deliver pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Bill Burr.
在 Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。我是尼克·图图罗。您可能通过《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》认识我。在我的新播客《尼克·图图罗传递幸福》中，我为一位新嘉宾送披萨。我和从塞思·罗林斯到比尔·伯尔的每个人都分享过一块披萨。你在对我的腰带做什么？
I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro. And listen now.
我想我从来没遇到过哪个人的疯狂程度和我如此不相上下。现在我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·图图罗。这个节目叫《幸福》。传递幸福。还有许许多多其他人。打开您免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Nick Totoro 的 Delivering Happiness》并立即收听。
I'm Jake Brennan. And on the Disgrace Land Podcast, I explode. the wild lies of rock stars and unbelievable true crime stories from music history. These are the stories you haven't heard, the kind you'll end up telling someone else. Like the time Paul McCartney spent in a notorious prison or the bizarre crime Lady Gaga is accused of where that time Blondie's Debbie Harry escaped Ted Bunny. Listen to Discraseland on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是杰克·布伦南。在《Disgraceland》播客中，我将揭秘摇滚巨星的疯狂谎言以及音乐史上难以置信的真实犯罪故事。这些都是你从未听过的事实，那种你会忍不住讲给别人听的故事。比如保罗·麦卡特尼在声名狼藉的监狱里度过的时光，或者Lady Gaga被指控的离奇罪行，又或者当年金发女郎乐队的黛比·哈里逃离泰德·邦迪魔爪的经历。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何您获取播客的地方收听 Disgraceland。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。